Hallo hallo oh hallo das ist ja witzig ihr seht alle so gut aus.
Schleimer.
Schleimer. Moment. Nee, andersrum.
Naja. so wir sind jetzt die beiden die die hände frei haben das heißt wir müssen
die ganze körperliche Arbeit verrichten.
Das ist das? Das ist das? Das ist das? Das ist das? Das ist das?
Das ist das? Und ich würde euch... Das steckt sein bisschen in die Tasche.
Ja, das ist das? Ja, das ist das? Ja, ich krieg's los. Ja.
Und ich würde euch bitten, kurz mal ein bisschen zu reden. Das ist das?
Also ich habe gehört, wir sollen mal kurz für die Lautstärke hinten ein bisschen reden.
Lorem Ipsum, Dolorsit, Ahmet, Adipuski, Elit. Ach, da geht das wieder los.
Also das Podcast können wir überhaupt nicht. Wir wissen gar nicht,
wie das geht mit dem Reden, glaube ich, als Podcast.
Alle gleichzeitig am besten. Ja, natürlich auch. Alle gleichzeitig können wir
natürlich, gut, wir machen einfach beide Sendungen parallel.
Wir machen jetzt ein Konzept, das das Konzept ist.
Ihr habt dann später auf der Aufzeichnung auf dem linken Kanal eine Folge akkumisierbar
und auf dem rechten Kanal eine Folge Reboot-Politik.
Das finde ich super kritisch, weil das ist bei ganz vielen nicht angekommen.
Das ist ja ein relativ großes Thema. Die Frage ist, an welcher Stelle fangen
wir jetzt an? Und es ist eine Phase, wo man von Seiten, wie wir solche Meinungen
haben, und ich meine, du hast nicht im Kontext.
Die ist, glaube ich, vorbei, mittlerweile.
Ich bin überfordert. Oder die Tee einfach.
Dass wir so nahtlos dann das andere Thema weiter besprechen müssen.
Das wäre noch abgefangen. Das wäre sehr witzig, wenn mich das nicht selber schon
beim Produzieren so durcheinander bringen würde, dass es niemals klappen wird.
Du arbeitest es nicht nach. Ich meine zu reden, während die anderen auch über was anderes reden.
Ich werde auf alle Fälle ein Disclaimer für unsere Hörner aufnehmen.
Die mögen nämlich die Struktur.
Eure sind sich schon viel gewohnt. Das tut mir leid.
Wir haben keine Ahnung, ob wir Hörende haben oder nicht. Wir wissen das nicht.
Wir haben noch einen Gruppenchat durchgezielt. Also ich habe mich gemeldet.
Ach stimmt, mindestens ihr. Mindestens ihr beide. Da ist noch jemand. Hallo.
Ja, drei Leute. Und mindestens einer von euch war selber noch nicht in der Sendung.
Bevor wir hier offiziell anfangen. Ich halte jetzt so.
So? Ja, ich halte falsch. Ich muss so drüber reden. So als würde ich Flaschenpusten
machen. Also nicht so, aber das ist das Bild.
Karotte?
Naja, aber so darf ich nicht. Achso. Doch, ich soll so. Dann mache ich es ja
gerade andersrum. Ich habe dich falsch verstanden.
Das ist immer schön, wenn danke.
Applaus für sowas.
Ja, geil.
Habt ihr uns schon durchgetestet? Funktioniert das? Sind wir theoretisch bereit für einen Stream?
Bei mir wurde vorhin gesagt, der Stream geht nicht und ich habe nie eine andere Info bekommen.
Er scheint immer noch nicht zu gehen. Ja.
Okay. Ah. Das ist doch schön, dass wir diese Sachen nie ändern.
Ich bin ja ein bisschen traurig, dass wir jetzt bloß die Keulen haben,
weil ich habe immer so, das sieht so wichtig aus.
Das sieht so aus, als würde man so richtig dazugehören. Deswegen habe ich mich
freiwillig gemeldet. Der Winter-Check-Typ ist da.
Wir lassen jetzt das, was in deinem Sein ist, lassen wir in deinem Sein machen, in die 19 Uhr rein.
Das war jetzt die Frage, ist das für dich in Ordnung? Ja, klar.
Wir haben einen Programminweis. Wir haben tatsächlich ein Ersatzprogramm für
den großen Saal für abends 19 Uhr.
Es wird einen Vortrag über Delta Chat geben.
Ich finde es gut, weil Messenger sind immer ein Diskussionsthema.
Habe ich noch nicht genug auf meinem Handy. Ja, eben. Geht mir ganz genauso.
Just one more lane, bro. Just one more messenger, trust me.
Na, während wir hier so überbrücken, wollt ihr mal erzählen,
wer ihr so seid? Ihr kommt so selten raus, euch kennt doch kein Mensch.
Deshalb rebooten wir euch. Das ist super. Ich wollte bloß eine kurze Frage.
Werden wir schon aufgezeichnet? Nee, nee.
Das läuft ja alles noch nicht, deshalb müssen wir die Trade jetzt füllen.
Eier. Aber ich denke, dass... Also was geht? Ihr könnt aufzeichnen, aber keinen streamen.
Dann machen wir es halt so. Wir brauchen ja für ein Podcast-Feed nicht unbedingt
den Stream, oder? Im Feed können wir den Stream nicht. Aber für das eigene Ego.
Mein Ego ist groß genug. Also wenn es die Entscheidung pro oder kontra,
dann wäre ich eher für aufzeichnen statt streamen.
Also hier warten ist Quark. Das ist wahr.
Die ganzen tollen Leute sind ja hier. Wir hören, die Aufnahme läuft da hinten.
Ich gucke da hinten hin. Wir haben tatsächlich ein Technikteam da hinten sitzen
und ich muss das nicht selber machen diesmal.
Das ist total super.
Ja, dann Applaus für die Technik und dann let's go.
Ihr fangt ja immer mit einem Gespräch an und wir sagen Ahoi.
Das schneiden wir aber meistens ein bisschen wild im Nachhinein.
Das solltest du nicht sagen. Das sind jetzt die Geheimnisse,
die ausgeplaudert werden.
Willkommen erst mal. Wir sind zwei Podcasts, die uns dazu entschieden haben,
hier zusammen eine Aufnahme zu machen.
Das ist Hendrik, ich bin Kilian, wir zusammen machen den Podcast Akronomisierbar.
Für die, die uns kennen, hi Kilian. Hi Hendrik. Hi Ök Ök und hi Zecki.
Ja, hi Kilian, hi Henrik. Ich sage Ahoi. Das machen wir gleich, wenn wir dran sind.
Genau, und was ihr wahrscheinlich besser kennt, ist den Podcast von Ök Ök und
Zecki, dem Podcast VibuPolitics.
Dresdner lokal, wie sagt man, ein grandioser Podcast aus der Region über Politik
und andere wichtige Themen. So was machen wir natürlich nicht.
Wir labern bloß über Dinge, die uns einfallen. Meistens ohne Schema,
meistens ohne Konzept. Aber es ist immer witzig.
Für uns ist das ein bisschen Therapie. Wir haben irgendwann mal uns gedacht,
wir erzählen uns gerne, was uns so interessiert.
Und damit ich das nicht aufschreiben muss, nehmen wir es einfach auf.
Damit es ein bisschen Struktur ist, tun wir so, als würden es andere Leute hören.
Und deswegen haben wir jetzt ein Konzept, das nennt sich akronomisierbar.
Seit etwa fünf Jahren machen wir das, oder? 2017.
Genau. Ihr wart sogar schon zweimal auf den Datenspuren und wir einmal.
Falls euch noch die coolen Datenspuren in den technischen Sammlungen erinnert, 2019?
20? 17. Nee, nee. Da haben wir in diesem coolen DDR-Tonstudio aufgenommen. Das war cool.
Und später mal woanders. Das
stimmt, wir hatten im Tonstudio drüben im Koloradio auch mit aufgenommen.
Er war 2017 und 2018 da.
Geil. Wir arbeiten mit organisierten Menschen zusammen.
Ekelhaft. Ungewohnt. Das ist mal vorher notiert worden, das hatte ich gerade im Pet gelesen.
Aber auf jeden Fall kam von Uecköck die tolle Idee, lasst doch mal gemeinsam
was machen und deswegen sitzen wir jetzt hier und wollen euch irgendwas erzählen.
Was, das wussten wir bis vor kurzem auch noch nicht so wirklich. Einfach reden.
Ja, also ich muss ja sagen, ich kenne das ja, oder wir haben ja schon mal mit
dir zumindest eine Sonderfolge gehabt zu Matrix und du hast mich schon mal ersetzt
in einer regulären Folge, weil ich krank war.
Matrix. Und da ist... Das ist einer unserer häufigsten beiden Gästinnen.
Da ist ja schon aufgefallen. Kurze Anmerkung, es gibt später noch einen ganz
tollen Talk zum Thema Matrix.
Ja, das stimmt. Das sind Arztspuren von Begesium. Am Sonntag.
Am Sonntag erst, okay, top.
Also bitte dahin gehen. Und dabei ist mir schon aufgefallen,
dass wir dazu neigen, weit abzuschweifen.
Deswegen weiß ich gar nicht, ob wir ein Thema brauchen.
Ja, aber jetzt nicht, um euch abzuschrecken. Wir haben uns tatsächlich ein bisschen
was überlegt. Ja, wir wollen jetzt nicht eine Stunde lang nur über uns selber
reden. Das reicht langsam.
Ja, genug Meter. Aber damit ihr zumindest ein Gefühl dafür habt,
wie diese Podcasts normalerweise klingen, ungefähr so.
Also unserer, Entschuldigung, eurer nicht. Unserer. Unserer ist planlos und
konzeptlos. Da gibt es Konzept.
Aber wir wollten ein bisschen über ein Thema reden, das sehr vielen Menschen
irgendwie, also wahrscheinlich schon sehr aus dem Hals raushängt.
Deswegen dachten wir, geil, da machen wir nochmal mit.
Wer kann es raten, was so ein Thema ist, was gerade ganz heiß ist,
was hier schon richtig überhaupt eigentlich.
Genau, wir reden über FreeBSD. Willkommen.
Andere Vorschläge? Blockchain. Blockchain. Das ist auch nicht schlecht, ja.
Wir kommen bei den Datenspuren 2022 über Blockchain, genau.
Nee, wir haben uns was viel Aktuelleres ausgesucht, nämlich haben wir Bock,
über KI zu reden und das tut mir jetzt schon leid, aber als KI-Lian liegt mir
das immer sehr am Herzen.
Genau, also wir haben ja jetzt tatsächlich ein Publikum, wir können vielleicht
ein bisschen Feedback annehmen, wer arbeitet von euch in seinem alltäglichen
Umfeld tatsächlich mittlerweile mit KI?
Bloß so ein kurzes Stimmungsbild oder wer schafft es, das komplett zu vermeiden?
Wer nutzt es? Wer nutzt es aktiv? Okay.
Wer kann es vermeiden oder wer macht einen großen Bogen drumherum?
Das hält sich einigermaßen in die Frage. Ich würde sagen, es können gerade mehr
vermeiden für die, die das hören. Es ist definitiv aber beide Seiten vertreten.
Aber ich sehe, dann haben wir dann trotzdem ein Thema gefunden,
was noch so ein bisschen das Publikum teilt. Das ist doch durchaus spannend.
An dieser Stelle der Übergang, das Problem mit KI ist ja, es kann alles und
es kann irgendwie nichts gleichzeitig.
Nichts richtig, würde ich sagen. Es kann alles, aber nichts richtig.
Und ich habe meistens das Problem, es ist genauso wie als diese Sprachassistenten aufkamen,
man weiß gar nicht, was es kann und was es nicht kann, man muss es so ein bisschen
erst herausfinden und dann damit spielen und man muss es benutzen, um zu verstehen,
was geht und was geht nicht und wo sind die Grenzen von den Möglichkeiten?
Es ist ja ein relativ großes Thema. Die Frage ist, an welcher Stelle fangen wir jetzt an?
Und es deutet so gerade so ein bisschen in die Richtung, wir gehen erst mal
von Seiten, wie wir persönliche Berührungspunkte mit haben.
Und gerade so, ich meine, wir arbeiten alle irgendwo mit Computern und Software
und Softwareentwicklung, viele von uns.
Und das fühlt sich so nach dem, also mittlerweile haben wir alle unsere eigenen
Berührungspunkte mit damit gesammelt und wissen, was für Tools existieren.
Es ist nicht mehr ganz so schwammig von wegen, ja, man kann mit Chat-GPT reden
oder so oder keine Ahnung, sondern es gibt mittlerweile Tools,
die explizit dafür existieren, dass wir mit diesen arbeiten können und damit auch Dinge tun können.
Und also ich möchte so ein bisschen von der Seite kommen. Ich nutze diese Tools.
Ich habe ein bisschen mich, also ich habe mich ausprobiert über die letzten
Jahre mittlerweile damit.
Ich nutze manche von denen auch sehr, sehr gerne, aber es gibt natürlich viele
Punkte, wo Grenzen aufgezeigt werden.
Ich möchte es auch nicht ganz so schwammig bleiben, Aber was ich mir so ein
bisschen so als Opening Statement auch mit zurechtgelegt habe,
ist das Ganze, was ich mal online gelesen habe, irgendein Random Hacker News
Kommentar, wie so alle meine Meinungen wahrscheinlich, die ich im Kopf recycle.
Das Ganze ist irgendwie gefühlt mehr so eine Art Floor Razor statt zu einem Ceiling Razor.
Also man schafft es, mehr Leute in den Bereich reinzukriegen.
Man schafft es, mehr Leute irgendwie dafür zu begeistern und Dinge anzugehen,
für die man sonst keine Zeit oder nicht die möglichen Befugnisse,
nicht Befugnisse, das ist falsch, weird, Möglichkeiten hätte, Fähigkeiten, danke.
Aber es ist schwer irgendwie auf das aufzubauen, was man eh schon mit hat.
Also du redest jetzt aber auch, um das ein bisschen klarzustellen über den Bereich
Softwareentwicklung. Ich rede jetzt erstmal ganz konkret im Bereich Softwareentwicklung.
Also jetzt mit, keine Ahnung, was für Tools existieren. Ihr kennt jetzt vielleicht,
was mir direkt einfällt, Open-Eyes-Codex oder Cloud-Code.
Ich will jetzt keine Werbung machen, aber nur um festzustellen,
von was ich hier spezifisch rede.
Also diese Tools, denen du sagst, ich möchte jetzt dieses Vor-Loop nicht ausformulieren.
Mach mir mal bitte diesen Algorithmus. Genau, genau. Und dann kommt GitHub Copilot
daher und sagt, hey, hier ist der Boilerplate, drückt Tab.
Dann liest man sich das durch und denkt sich, das sieht eigentlich okay aus
und eine halbe Stunde später stellt man fest, dass irgendwas zu machen wird.
Ich wollte aber noch gar nicht gleichzeitig dazu, dass viele Leute...
Halt das eigentlich, also die eigentliche Fähigkeit verlieren,
weil sie sich nur noch auf das Tool verlassen?
Genau, genau. Das ist ein Punkt, der mir sehr wichtig mit ist.
Also die Büchse der Pandora ist so oder so offen.
Aber ich finde, wir haben jetzt Möglichkeiten, die auch so ein bisschen zu gestalten.
Also wir können jetzt irgendwie Richtung offene Schnittstellen das Ganze ein
bisschen mehr demokratisieren, Sachen on device schieben, damit wir mehr Privacy
haben und nicht unsere Daten auch direkt als Trainingsdaten Firmen zurechtstellen,
bereitstellen, dem wir das gar nicht geben wollen.
Wir können Transparenz schaffen und wir können vor allem, und das ist für mich
ein sehr wichtiger Punkt, durch passendes Tool-Design, also durch die Gestaltung
dieser Werkzeuge, das Ganze so gestalten, dass wir versuchen,
Lernen zu fördern und nicht Leute zu de-skillen.
Also nicht, dass man am Ende nur noch da sitzt und quasi die KI bestätigt,
ja, ja, ja, für den Commander, das Bash-Command sieht richtig aus,
ja, ja, RM, keine Ahnung, mach einfach. Was sich alles unter Vibe-Coding vorstellen.
Genau, also Vibe-Coding ist für mich noch ein bisschen weiter losgelöst davon,
im Sinne von, du brauchst gar nicht hinschauen, sondern die KI macht schon und
wenn es nicht klappt, dann sagst du einfach nochmal, was nicht klappt und die KI kümmert sich.
Idealerweise musst du ja nicht mal mehr das machen. Der Begriff Vibe-Coding sagt euch was, oder?
Ja, ja. Es sind auch Leute von uns da, die Politik gewöhnt sind.
Genau, also wir kommen auch, wir shiften gleich ein bisschen,
erweitern das Feld und gehen auch in eine andere Richtung.
Aber ich finde, man hat da sehr viele Möglichkeiten. Man kann gerade in diesem
Bereich wirklich auch, wir sind jetzt an einem Punkt, wo klar,
es sieht erstmal alles sehr wild aus.
Und es gibt sehr viel, was so wirkt, als ob wir jetzt in eine neue Ära kommen,
wo wir uns selber abschaffen, wo, keine Ahnung, unser Management daherkommt
und sagt, nee, Job brauche man nicht mehr.
Das lässt sich alles einfach wegautomatisieren. Ich klaue einfach die Karrieren,
das Jira-Ticket ran und tada, was brauche ich das überhaupt?
Aber man muss es halt nicht ganz so fatalistisch sehen.
Man hat auch ganz, also meiner Meinung nach, sehr viele Möglichkeiten.
Wir sind jetzt eben an so einem Punkt, wo man damit sehr viel in der Hand hat
und durch passende Tools halt auch sehr viel Zukunft mitgestalten kann.
Ich habe so ein bisschen den Eindruck, dieses Tool wurde vor ein,
zwei, drei Jahren so in die Welt gesetzt und man hat am Anfang gedacht, ja, das kann das alles.
Du sagst ihm einfach Programmieren und dann programmiert es und dann stellt
man fest, Es klappt nicht.
Und dann gab es den Begriff Vibe Coding und man hat sich gedacht,
okay, man sagt einfach, ja, mach weiter, mach weiter, mach ein bisschen anders
und lässt das machen und verliert den Skill des Handwerklichen, des Selbermachens.
Aber auch selbst das scheint meiner Erfahrung nach nicht so richtig einzutreten,
weil du doch relativ viel reviewen und kontrollieren musst, was da passiert.
Und was ich so beobachte, ist, dass wir so als Gesellschaft,
als die Leute, die diese Tools benutzen, so ein bisschen den Umgang damit in
den letzten ein, zwei, drei Jahren gelernt haben und so ein bisschen lernen,
wie man damit umgeht, was damit geht. Sehr wohl noch lernen, ja, ja.
Und immer noch lernen und das Spannende ist, da ist plötzlich so ein mächtiges,
unbeschreibbares Werkzeug da und was wir uns jetzt erarbeiten,
ist gerade, wie benutzen wir es?
Also es gab in irgendeinem, ich möchte überhaupt einen furchtbaren Film,
so eine Analogie, da ist plötzlich so eine Coca-Cola-Flasche irgendwo in einem
Dorf gelandet. Ah, the gods must be crazy.
Und die Leute wussten nicht, was man damit macht, aber dieses Glas ist ziemlich
hart, also haben sie angefangen, damit auf Sachen einzuhämmern.
Ja, und dass man damit, erst später hat sich herausgestellt,
man kann damit auch andere Sachen machen, man kann zum Beispiel Flüssigkeiten
reinfüllen und das irgendwie präziser und genauer nutzen.
Ich glaube, das Vibe-Coding mit dem Sachem einfach, was es tun soll und ich
iteriere so lange, bis es irgendwann klappt,
das ist so das drauf einhämmern und nicht richtig und eventuell entwickelt sich
so der Usage davon so ein bisschen davon weg und wir werden so ein bisschen cleverer.
Aber vielleicht ist das jetzt auch so langsam der Punkt, wo wir das Gespräch
so ein bisschen von diesem Sofa auf dieses Sofa mal ganz kurz abgeben.
Was ist denn euer Take auf das ganze Thema?
Ihr seid nur zum Teil Softwareentwickler. Ich würde schon mal vielleicht erst
mal anfangen, weil ich glaube, ich bin noch ein bisschen versöhnlicher als du. Du bist der Übergang.
Du sitzt ja dir total verweigerend. Genau.
Ich kann es nicht vermeiden, KI zu benutzen in einem beruflichen Kontext.
Also einfach, weil ich habe sozusagen nicht die, also das wird mir ja sozusagen
vorgeschrieben, dass ich das nutzen sollte. Krass, okay.
Also ich glaube, es ginge auch, also ohne, aber... Was heißt das?
Ja, halt so nach dem Motto, wenn man jetzt
irgendwie, also ich bin ja auch Softwareentwickler und wenn man eben dann,
also dass man eben eher nicht mehr eine Suchmaschine bedient,
sondern eher sozusagen sagen wir mal, bei einer KI nachfragt und dann selber
vielleicht nochmal nachrecherchiert, wenn irgendwas nicht ganz passt.
Das haben wir aber auch bei einem spannenden anderen Use Case auch mit.
Also genau das ist halt so ein Ding von wegen KI als Suchmaschine.
Was natürlich sehr viele Leute sehr kritisch sehen. Und also inwiefern das wirklich
diesen Zweck erfüllen kann, dass du halt in den Trainingsdaten Fakten suchst,
ist halt was ganz, ganz anderes.
Es geht in dem Fall ja aber nicht unbedingt direkt. Also es geht natürlich schon
um Fakten, aber es geht halt ja darum, eher vielleicht nicht eine ganz so konkrete
Vorstellung zu haben, was man jetzt eigentlich genau sucht und erstmal sozusagen
so einen Überblick zu kriegen,
um dann daraus vielleicht nochmal eine Idee zu kriegen, okay,
wonach muss ich vielleicht nochmal genauer suchen oder, also das wäre jetzt ein Beispiel.
Ich mache das selber. Man kann dem Ding dümmere Fragen stellen,
als man vorher als Google-Suche hätte angegeben.
Also dieses Ding, was du und so und so und das verhält sich und wie heißt das?
Und sowas geht plötzlich. Das ging vorher nicht. Da hättest du keine sinnvollen
Suchergebnisse bekommen. Genau.
Aber privat muss ich sagen, vermeide ich es so gut es geht. Also benutze es eigentlich gar nicht.
Und es ist halt, bin da auch nicht so ein großer, also es gibt für mich noch
zu viele Probleme, also nicht nur in der Qualität, sondern auch eben in dem,
was dahinter ist, also mit,
Ressourcenverbrauch und natürlich auch Urheberrecht und so weiter,
was ja alles nicht so richtig geklärt ist.
Ja, deswegen ist das bei mir, ich bin da so zwiegespalten, also beruflich nutze
ich es privat nicht. Wie ist es bei dir?
Der Blick sagt schon alles.
Ich spoiler erst mal, dass diese schönen Sachen mit Urheberrecht und Energie
und so ja meine Notizen waren und meine Kontrapunkte, aber zusätzlich...
Ja gut, aber das wusste ich auch so.
Ja, aber ich glaube, ich bin die, die wahrscheinlich noch am meisten mit den
Nicht-Techies zu tun hat von uns und ganz viele wissen halt auch nicht,
wie es funktioniert und was dahinter steckt und ich liebe immer diese Promi-Beispiele,
die es so gibt, wenn man jetzt so, weiß ich nicht,
Ehefrau von Schauspieler XY sucht und dann kommen da irgendwelche halluzinierten
Ergebnisse von einer Person,
die eigentlich schwul ist zum Beispiel und das ist halt kaputt und im Zweifelsfall
kannst du mit der gleichen offenen
KI, wenn die unterschiedlich quasi antrainiert ist von deinem Konto,
verschiedene Antworten dann kriegen zu einer Person und das.
Das finde ich super kritisch, weil das ist bei ganz vielen nicht angekommen.
Da hatten wir vor zwei Jahren, glaube ich, dieses wunderschöne kleine Lein-Theater-Schauspiel
mit interaktiven Sachen hier auf der Bühne im Abendprogramm.
Da kam dann raus, dass es Chaos im Namen der Liebe geben würde.
Gibt es leider bis heute immer noch nicht.
Wir haben uns dann ausgesprochen, das ist ein Dating-Pro. Aber das waren damals
so Live-Antworten von Chat-GPT. und das ist halt immer noch da.
Also ich weiß, es ist schlimmer geworden, kommt drauf an.
Also es werden gerade beide Thesen vertreten. Das ist einmal natürlich,
weil der Pool der halluzinierten Ergebnisse größer wird und dadurch das,
was reinkommt, wieder falscher ist,
dass das natürlich an sich die Ergebnisse verschlechtert, aber es gibt auch
mittlerweile bessere Filter.
Also kommt halt sehr drauf an, was du nutzt.
Das fällt für mich so ein bisschen unter die Kategorie von wir lernen damit umzugehen.
Also dieses, was man vielleicht vor ein, zwei Jahren noch gemacht hat,
dass man Chat-GPT was fragt und Chat-GPT so aus seinem inneren Weltwissen Antworten
erzeugt, das ist ja häufig gar nicht mehr...
Gar nicht mehr so richtig nützlich. Ich kann mich an ein Beispiel von einem
Kollegen von mir erinnern, der wollte seiner Frau ein Buch schenken, der hat dann gesagt,
sie mag so diese Genres und solche Themen und dann hat das irgendwie,
halt die ersten drei Bücher gab es und den Rest waren plausibel andere Buchtitel,
die nur noch geschrieben hätten werden müssen, aber die gab es halt nicht.
Und wenn du heutzutage so eine Frage in.
Chatschipetit beispielsweise reinpastest, geht ja erstmal los,
Websuche, Websuche und dann ist es dahinter dann trotzdem wieder etwas,
was sich verhält wie ein Computer.
Und das Sprachmodell ist dann quasi nur noch dazu da, die Inhalte für dich sprachlich
zusammenzufassen. Also das scheint ein bisschen besser zu werden.
Wenn du dem jetzt natürlich nach hinten irgendwie seine Datenquelle zum richtigen
Internet abklemmst, dann fängst du plötzlich wieder an, das zu überlegen.
Aber das ist, du musst, und das ist, was wir irgendwie als Nutzer lernen mussten,
ich kann dem was Doofes fragen, dann kriege ich eine Antwort.
Und wenn ich die glaube, bin ich selber dran schuld, weil häufig ist die halt
irgendwie zusammengesponnen.
Also ich will jetzt nicht sagen, selber dran schuld ist natürlich ein bisschen
blöd formuliert, aber man muss halt irgendwie lernen, damit umzugehen,
dass man dem nicht ohne weiteres vertrauen kann und es wird aber sukzessive
so ein bisschen besser, wie der Umgang davon ist.
Das ist so positiv, das beobachte ich gar nicht.
Also die Medienkompetenz vor vielen
Jahren war ja... Das M-Wort wäre jetzt wieder... Ja, es tut mir leid.
Ich weiß, dass ich berechenbar bin. Aber es ist ja komplexer dadurch geworden
und wenn ich mich umgucke, also allein so in meiner piratigen Bubble,
dass Leute einfach KI-Sachen generieren für Sharepics, irgendwelche Videos und
so, das nicht kennzeichnen, dass einfach nicht gecheckt wird, was hinten rausfällt,
weil der Trope am Anfang war ja richtig und dann kommen irgendwelche Quatschergebnisse
und dann werden die vervollgenommen.
Also das sehe ich selbst bei Leuten, die es besser wissen müssten.
Und dann gibt es noch Leute wie meine Mutter. Oh ja. Und das ist ein bisschen
das Problem an der Geschichte.
Ja, das beobachte ich bei mir in der Familie auch, dass es wirklich als Suchmaschine benutzt wird.
Aber es ist ja, um das für mich im Kopf mit einzuordnen, es ist ja nicht nur
das Beispiel immer von wegen, ja, die Menschen da draußen, die fallen auf KI-Sachen rein.
Und wir wissen ja, wir kennen ja, und wir erkennen die ja als solche und wissen die einzuordnen.
Und eigentlich müssen wir alle damit klarkommen. Ich habe letztens erst gecheckt,
dass dieses tolle, schöne kleine WWQ, wie dieses vertikale, virale Kurzvideo
von den Hasen auf dem Trampolin, was ich voll toll fand, dass das auch KI-generierter Slop war und so.
Wir sind alle schon drauf reingefallen, ob wir es wollen oder nicht, auch ihr.
Also das hat man halt bloß nicht gemerkt und genau das Ding ist,
dass halt man kann halt argumentieren, klar, dass man da irgendwie,
Medienkompetenz schulen muss und das sollte man auf jeden Fall immer,
ganz klar, gar keine Frage, aber wir werden so oder so, leben wir in einer Welt,
wo das schon gang und gäbe ist.
Und das wird, also nochmal zurück auf die Büchse der Pandora,
die ist da, die ist offen, da kommen wir nicht mehr weg von.
Der Content ist jetzt da, der Content wird auch niemals komplett als solches
gekennzeichnet sein. Das wird nie der Fall sein.
Also diese Phase, wo man KI-erzeugte Bilder als solche relativ klar mit vielleicht
noch einem geschulten Blick und ein bisschen schärferer Hinsehen erkennt,
die ist glaube ich vorbei,
mittlerweile, aber gleichzeitig ist es tatsächlich auch so, gefakte Inhalte.
Die dich manipulieren sollen oder die nicht echt sind die gab es auch schon vorher,
hieß es Photoshop selbst vor 100 Jahren hat Stalin schon seine Kontrahenten
aus Fotos raus retuschieren lassen und jetzt ist es halt an dem Punkt angekommen
den du gesagt hast jetzt kann das halt jeder so ja,
Da gab es eine schöne Aussage online für KI skaliert den Output, nicht die Nachfrage.
Wir haben halt plötzlich viel mehr Scheiße. Die Spam-E-Mails werden besser.
Vor allem kann sie auch schnell antworten, die Spam-E-Mail und dich noch mehr einlullen.
Klar, es gibt natürlich jetzt, wir leben in einer Welt mit viel mehr Slop.
Ich weiß nicht, was wir damit anfangen. Ich habe gerade auf dem Weg hierher
die letzte Lage der Nation gehört, die mich auch mal so richtig runtergerissen hat, inhaltlich.
Und dann war auch noch dieser Aspekt, den du vorhin kurz in der Vorbereitung
noch zu mir meintest, von wegen, ja, wollen wir vielleicht mal darüber reden,
wer diese ganzen KI-Firmen sind und wo die jetzt politisch mit verankert sind
und wer am schnellsten Trump in den Arsch kriecht.
Ja, okay, da möchte ich gleich wieder weinen.
Aber also, ich weiß nicht so recht, das war jetzt keine Überleitung in meinem
Kopf, aber in meinem Kopf klang es besser als in echt.
Aber wie kommen wir, also, okay, muss nochmal anfangen.
So klingt unser Podcast übrigens, sehr durcheinander. Suchst du den Übergang
zu den Abhängigkeiten von diesen Firmen?
Ich wollte irgendwie dahin, dass wir, also es gibt diese Sachen,
man generiert sehr viel Scheiße damit.
Man kann auch, finde ich, immer noch sehr angenehme Sachen damit machen.
Also ich persönlich, wie gesagt, nochmal an dem Beispiel am Anfang bleiben,
ich habe für mich gemerkt, ich kann sehr gut jetzt Projekte angehen,
von denen ich vorher keine Ahnung hatte, kann mich in neue Projekte reinfuchsen.
Ich habe Möglichkeiten dazu gewonnen. Ich fühle mich bekräftigt in manchen Sachen,
aber in vielen anderen Aspekten müssen wir halt jetzt in einer Welt leben,
wo es anders ausschaut und.
Ein großer Kritikpunkt an der Sache ist halt auch, wer dahinter steht und welchen
Firmen wir damit Geld geben, welchen Firmen wir damit Macht geben,
welchen Regierungen wir damit unglaubliche Macht geben, wie die noch Einfluss nehmen.
Vielleicht können wir an der Stelle mal ganz kurz den ersten Aspekt,
den du gerade erwähnt hattest, nochmal kurz beleuchten, weil den fand ich ja
nicht ganz interessant.
Du hattest in einer der letzten Folgen mal gesagt, AI-generierte Content ist
so ein bisschen wie Träume, die interessieren dich nicht, wenn sie von anderen kommen.
Deine eigene faszinierend. Ich merke immer wieder, dass man so eine gewisse
sofortige Abneigung oder ein sofortiges Desinteresse, das geht zumindest bei
mir so, empfindet, wenn ich merke, mir zeigt jemand was, was KI generiert ist
oder ich sehe irgendwo was, was KI generiert ist.
Ich mir denke meistens, das hätte ich auch selber machen können.
Also das dahingehen und das prompten, dann habe ich sowas. Also du brauchst
es nicht mehr verkaufen.
Aber was, wo ich gerade merke, was du beschrieben hast, was es so als kategorischen
Unterschied gibt, ist dieses, ich mache KI-generierten Content für mich selber,
zum Beispiel, um aus Spaß mir mal ein kleines Entenbildchen,
habe ich vorhin gemacht, so ein kleines Entenbildchen in der Situation,
in der ich war, zum Spaß zu generieren.
Und das andere Gegenüberstellen ist, ich generiere AI-Bilder für andere, weil ich zum Beispiel,
ihr kennt vielleicht diese KI-generierten Videos, so Fake-Nachrichtenbeiträge,
wo beschrieben wird, dass die USA jetzt in Kanada eingefallen sind und sowas,
wo du denkst, oh Gott, oh Gott, ich hoffe, meine Eltern sehen sowas nicht. ja.
Das ist so ein kategorischer Unterschied, finde ich. Ich finde es witzig,
es ist super witzig, so ein kleines Video oder so ein kleines Bild mal zu generieren,
dann schaust du dir das an, denkst dir,
ich hätte es vorher nicht malen können, weil ich nicht malen kann,
ja, und ich versuche aber nicht irgendwie einem Künstler irgendwie seine Butter
vom Brot zu nehmen oder irgendwie da Geld mit zu verdienen, sondern ich habe
den kleinen Spaß mal für mich selber gemacht.
Aber wenn du jetzt hingehst und sagst, du machst irgendwie Content und versuchst
damit zum Beispiel Menschen zu manipulieren oder so Fake News zu verbreiten,
das ist dann nochmal eine komplett andere Geschichte Und da ist halt die spannende Frage,
A, die du schon angesprochen hattest, das ist ja antrainiert,
selbst das Zweck für mich selber, was ich generiere, ist ja antrainiert auf Material,
wo Urheber jetzt nicht properly entlohnt worden sind. Das ist eine Sache.
Das andere ist, jetzt habe ich einen Faden verloren,
der andere Nachteil ist halt, du hast...
Die glaubhaft genug sind, um damit Leute zu manipulieren. Das ist halt gefährlich.
Ich muss halt sagen, ich finde tatsächlich auch, also wenn du zum Beispiel Bilder
generieren lässt oder noch schlimmer Videos,
das hat noch einen anderen negativen Aspekt, der auch zutrifft,
wenn du das für dich privat machst, weil es eben einen sehr hohen Ressourcenverbrauch hat.
Wenn du jetzt bloß sozusagen Text erzeugen lässt, ist das noch relativ energiesparend,
in Anführungszeichen. Aber Bilder und Videos wird dann schon wieder ganz schön heftig.
Aber auch da kommen wir also irgendwann dahin, dass man das Zeug halt auch lokal machen kann.
Klar, der Energieverbrauch ist auch lokal da. Aber ich weiß nicht,
ob ich mich gerade zu weit aus dem Fenster lehne.
Aber ich meine, das ist alles ein Tropfen auf den heißen Stein im Vergleich
zu den Trainings, also dem Antrainieren von den Modellen. Ja,
das kann schon sein, das stimmt, ja.
Aber klar, irgendwo, ja. Ich verstehe total das Argument an der Sache und klar
ist es mehr, als wenn man es nicht machen würde, gar keine Frage.
Ich persönlich finde es manchmal ein bisschen schwierig, so dieses Energieverbrauch-Dings,
weil wir als Menschheit ja auch natürlich irgendwie Energie verbrauchen mit
Neuentwicklung von Dingen.
Aber das ist nicht so sinnlos für irgendeinem Spielzeug.
Wie hieß das? Eine Kugelsuche verbraucht so viel, wie wenn man eine Glühbirne
eine Stunde lang brennen lässt oder sowas und eine GPT-Anfrage ist zehn- oder hundertfache.
Das kann man im Hinterkopf behalten.
Es wird wahrscheinlich über die Dauer eher auch wieder ein Stückchen runtergehen.
Auf der anderen Seite benutzen wir es dann wieder mehr.
Es gibt einen Effekt, dass es seitdem es mehr und mehr LED-Beleuchtung gibt,
verbrauchen wir eigentlich mehr Strom durch Beleuchtung, weil wir denken,
ah ja, es ist ja billig und es braucht ja nicht so viel. Können wir mehr Lampen machen?
Das ist ein valider Punkt.
Ja, aber ja, sorry.
Und du hast aber vorhin noch etwas Interessantes gesagt, wo ich auch noch mal
nachfragen wollte, weil ich finde es spannend.
Du kannst sozusagen neue Dinge lernen mithilfe der KI oder was?
Weil ich finde, das geht übelst schlecht, weil die halt nur Scheiße erzählen.
Das ist halt die Frage. Also Lernen ist so ein Ding.
Klar kannst du dich hinsetzen und versuchen explizit was zu lernen.
Aber worauf ich hinaus wollte, ist, ich kann mich halt wirklich mit Problemen
auseinandersetzen, für die ich sonst keine Zeit hätte und nicht das nötige Know-how.
Wenn ich hier ein Beispiel explizit, ich habe letztens das wunderbare Spiel
Open Clonk entdeckt. Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr Clonk noch kennt. Geiles Spiel.
Open Clonk ist ein Open Source Re-Write davon, der leider auf macOS keinen aktiven
Bild hatte und das war für mich so, fuck, ich will das aber, ich will das spielen.
Setze ich mich mal hin, ich habe keinerlei Möglichkeiten, mich in diese C++
Codebase einzuarbeiten, also dieses Ding ist,
mein C++ alleine schon, aber das Projekt als solches, da habe ich eigentlich
die Möglichkeiten, das nötige Know-how zu, um mich damit auseinanderzusetzen,
aber ich kann mich halt für mich privat hinsetzen und schauen,
ob ich irgendwie diesen Bild gefixt bekomme und mich da reinfuchsen,
aber wirklich also quasi mit der Hilfestellung, nicht von wegen,
mach mal, sondern lass mal investieren, gelten und dann ach ja,
okay, das klingt sinnvoll und dann schauen wir mal,
liegt es irgendwie an SDL, schauen wir mal, ob wir da irgendwas hinkriegen,
dann suche ich halt nebenbei, aber das ist so ein, so quasi so ein Miteinander
in ganz großen Anführungsstrichen, von wegen, von mit jemandem, der halt mehr,
also jemand, ich anthropomorphiziere diese Karriere ein bisschen,
aber mit etwas, was halt das nötige Hintergrundwissen mitbringt,
das ich nicht habe und mit dessen Hilfe ich halt da hinkomme zu meinem Ziel.
Das ist das Wort, was ich damit sagen wollte. Also diese Ermöglichung,
die sehe ich für mich persönlich als unglaublich powerful an.
Also das ist für mich persönlich eine unglaubliche Bereicherung.
Aber das hat überhaupt gar nichts damit zu tun, dass wir halt,
keine Ahnung, im Sinne von Medienerzeugung oder dass Leute halt,
LLMs, sind für mich ein Werkzeug für Sprache und nicht für Wahrheit.
Also Fakten gehören halt immer irgendwie überprüft und ich kann das LLM nicht
als Suchmaschine missbrauchen und dann, beziehungsweise explizit Google,
wenn wir Wir sagen immer googeln, wir meinen damit wahrscheinlich andere Plattformen,
aber wenn ich explizit jetzt Google frage,
wie schaffe ich das, der Käse auf meiner Pizza hält und Google mir sagt,
indem ich den Käse mit Kleber vermische, echtes Beispiel, dann ist es natürlich Quark.
Suchmaschinen ist nochmal ein anderes Thema, aber in den meisten Fällen ist
es am Ende dann doch Google oder halt Bing oder halt, ihr wisst schon, was ich meine.
Nee, was? Ich meine, die ganzen Suchmaschinen laufen ja am Ende trotzdem immer
wieder über die großen. Okay, ja.
Also Indizes aufbauen ist auch schwierig und ein großes Problem.
Ich persönlich nutze Dr. Go und Kagi und bin damit sehr happy.
Aber klar, was die jetzt underlying store benutzen und Index ist natürlich blach.
Aber ja, ich meine jetzt übrigens gerade mit dem Google-Beispiel nicht explizit
die Suchmaschine fragen, sondern am Beispiel Google, dass die halt auch wirklich
KI-Mittel draufwerfen und mir diesen Blurber am Anfang noch geben,
der mir die Antwort in Anführungsstrichen liefert.
Die auch irgendwie 99% der Fälle falsch ist, oder?
Das wäre eine schöne Kategorie gewesen und zwar so Slop Beispiele aus eurem Alltag.
Also Slop Beispiele. So Situationen, wo Produkte und Firmen,
wo Firmen in ihre Produkte KI eingebaut haben, wo ihr denkt,
das hättest du jetzt echt nicht mehr gebraucht.
Ein Beispiel ist, selbst Dr. Go hat oben jetzt AI-Antworten,
die dir die Suchergebnisse zusammenfassen, was ich,
prinzipiell als jetzt nicht komplett falsch wahrnehme, weil du ja einen Suchmaschinen-Korpus
hast und dir diesen beschränkten Inhalt.
Diesen eingegrenzten Inhalt irgendwie nochmal sprachlich kurz zusammenfasst.
Das können die Dinger gut.
Ein bisschen Sprachkontext nehmen und irgendwie umformulieren und zusammenfassen.
Noch schlimmer finde ich es eigentlich bei Ecosia, weil die sich ja quasi auf
die Fahne schreiben, besonders ökonomisch. Ecosia ist sowieso so einer Queen-Rushing.
Ja, klar.
Also es ist schon klar, aber das ist halt nochmal obendrauf sozusagen.
Dass du dann sagst, okay, wir wollen halt voll irgendwie so Umweltbewusstsein, wir benutzen KI.
Ist das dann so ein Ding, dass die halt den Marktdruck verspüren und Wünsche
von ihren Kundinnen bekommen, von wegen, baut mal KI-Features ein?
Ich habe keine Ahnung. Ich schätze, das ist einfach das Hauptding,
warum Firmen KI bei sich einbauen.
Es gab vor einem Jahr oder länger eine Marktanalyse, dass Firmen,
die irgendwie AI erwähnen, einen höheren Börsenwert haben als Firmen, die das nicht tun.
Also macht ihr da ein bisschen irgendwas. Wir müssen diese Checkbox erfüllen
und jetzt haben wir auch was mit AI.
Okay, warte mal. Ich will noch mal eine Publikumsfrage stellen.
Bei euch sind ja einige Leute unter euch sicherlich Softwareentwicklerinnen.
Bitte meldet euch mal, falls ihr irgendwie von Management oder Upper Management
schon mal den Wunsch bekommen habt, KI-Features einzubauen und ihr nicht wirklich
verstanden habt, warum oder wofür die da sind.
Ich sehe ein paar wenige Meldungen. Okay. Eine Anzahl Hände größer.
Ja, gut, okay. Vier, fünf Meldungen. Ja, ja. Okay.
Also das Slop-Beispiel, sinnloses Slop-Beispiel, was ich nämlich bringen wollte,
ist, ich benutze eine Sport-App, die ich jetzt nicht namentlich bewerben möchte,
wo man so tracken kann, wo bin ich
Radfahren gewesen oder wo war ich Wandern und die fasst einem dann hinterher
meine Rennradtour zusammen mit,
der Geschwindigkeit und so alles und die hat jetzt diesen...
So eine orange Plattform, meinst du? orange eine Plattform.
Und die hat dieses neue Feature, das heißt auch AI, das heißt nämlich Athlete Intelligence. Ach so.
Und das fasst mir diese paar Zahlen, die meine Tour produziert hat,
als für mich weniger accessible Fließtext wieder zusammen und sagt,
hey, das war jetzt ein Solid Ride, du warst schneller als dein Deutsch.
Das ist ja schon, das ist ja grundsätzlich immer das Allerbeste,
dass man irgendwie so auch, selbst wenn du, also es ist ja schon so,
wenn du von irgendwelchen Behörden einen Brief bekommst, dass immer so in so
zwei Seiten Fließtext irgendwie so drei Informationen drinstecken. Ja, genau.
Also da waren schon, das ist so, dass die Antithese ist, Zahlen und Werte möchte
ich visuell dargestellt schmackhaft gemacht bekommen.
Das ist ja eine hohe Kunst, irgendwie Zahlen und Werte zu visualisieren und anschaulich zu machen.
Und was man halt auch machen kann, ist einfach da wieder einen Text draus zu
machen, den ich dann lesen kann. Das ist einfach lazy as fuck.
Lazy Slop quasi so als Beispiel. Ja, aber du hast Das muss ich auch zugeben,
das mit dem zusammenfassen, das kann es tatsächlich ganz gut.
Ich glaube, das habt ihr auch in der Art genutzt für eure Suchmaschine durch eure eigenen Folgen.
Das fand ich ja irgendwie einen spannenden Anwendungsfall. Das hatten wir ein
Projekt vor einer Stunde und das hat sehr schlecht funktioniert,
möchte ich an dieser Stelle sagen.
Aber das sind so Sachen, wo ich Potenzial sehe, dass man das als bessere Suchmaschine benutzen kann.
Ja, den Begriff Suchmaschine in deinen Klammern setzen. Oder besseres User.
Simon Willison hat das mal schön beschrieben als ein Language Model.
Es ist halt ein Calculator for Words. Also man kann damit Sprache zusammenfassen
oder sowas wie ausformulieren oder generell irgendwie so Aktionen auf Tokens
irgendwie ausführen, auf Text, aber es ist halt nicht mehr als das.
Und alles, was mehr als das ist, wird halt schnell in diese problematische Richtung
gehen und halt explizit, was Sie vorhin schon mehrfach gesagt haben,
in die Richtung Suchmaschine oder als Wahrheitsquelle eben mitgehen.
Ja, okay, sorry. Nee, ich wollte ein bisschen überleiten.
Das Problem bei LLMs ist halt, die müssen mächtiger sein, als sie sollten.
Also Sprache ist so ein komplexes Konstrukt, dass du trotzdem ein LLM brauchst,
was in der Lage ist, Gedichte zu formulieren und Reime zu bilden.
Und es muss wissen, wer Klaus Stürtebecker ist oder wer random Beispiel.
Es muss ein gewisses Weltwissen haben und nicht, damit du es dann fragen kannst
zu diesen Fakten, weil die wird es potenziell falsch kriegen.
Wenn du mich jetzt fragst, wann wurde Klaus Stürtebecker geköpft,
dann würde ich dir wahrscheinlich die falsche Zahl nennen. Aber wenn du es glaubhaft
drüberbringst, glaube ich.
Aber ich könnte was halluzionieren, aber darum geht es nicht.
Man kann es auch so überzeugend drüberbringen. Ich brauche dieses gewisse Mindestmenge
an Weltwissen und Verständnis um menschliche Sprache Du kannst Sprache nicht kontextfrei lernen.
Du brauchst diesen Kontext, um zum Beispiel Metaphern in Sprache zu verstehen,
um irgendwie damit ich als Benutzer von so einem LLM nicht dahin zurückfalle,
wo es bei Siri oder bei Alexa ist, dass du.
Zaubersprüche lernen musst.
Dass du lernen musst, welche Texte darf ich sagen, damit es funktioniert.
Wie muss ich es formulieren, damit es funktioniert. Wenn du das Weltwissen halt
nicht aus den Daten dann rausziehst, aus den Trainingsdaten,
sondern aus sowas wie Wikidata im Hintergrund dagegen querying kannst,
dann kannst du ja auch mit tatsächlich korrekten Fakten antworten.
Dein Modell muss halt nur verstehen, wann es das tut. Aber ich finde das auch
gerade eine ganz wunderbare Überleitung zur Nutzung von KI in Politik.
Da habe ich nämlich ein paar tolle Notizen von euch gesehen. Ja.
Ich meine, ich lebe generell für Drama, aber ich habe da so ein paar schöne
politische Fails gesehen.
Wollen wir Fails oder wollen wir ein bisschen rechtliche Regulierung machen?
Womit wollen wir denn? Also ich finde, wir könnten erstmal mit den Fails anfangen,
weil das ja jetzt schon so schön übergeleitet hat.
Kannst du vielleicht erstmal, weil ich habe jetzt schon so viel erzählt.
Ja, also wir haben ja ein ganz wunderbares Kabinett.
Katharin Reicher hat schon wieder eine neue Expertinnenrunde,
mittlerweile die dritte, einberufen. und ich finde es einfach lustig und ich
muss ein bisschen davon erzählen, weil ihr habt euch ja auch explizit Politik-Fails
gewünscht. Bitte, bitte. Auf jeden Fall.
Das ist so ein bisschen wie Bösewichtinnen aus so einem Comic oder so.
Also unsere Bundeswirtschaftsministerin, CDU, für die, die es gerade nicht wissen,
hat jetzt die Expertinnen-Kommission für Künstliche Intelligenz und Wettbewerb einberufen.
Und Wettbewerb. Also ist noch dabei. Ganz toll. Wie hängen diese zwei Themenbereiche miteinander?
Naja, also ein bisschen wie es vorhin hatte. du musst halt in KI sein,
um wettbewerbsfähiger zu sein, auch als Land.
Ist das wie dieses geile Argument? Ich weiß gerade nicht mehr, wer das gebracht hat.
Ich glaube, das war aber auch in der Lage der Nationen genannt.
Nee, das war bei Lockup-Nicht-Politik genannt, von wegen, dass die EPA,
also die elektronische Patientenakte so ein tolles Ding ist,
weil das ist ja KI-ready, weil unverschlüsselte Daten und weil andere Staaten
jetzt neidisch sind auf uns. Ja.
KI-ready ist ein schöner Euphemismus. Total, Themen, die sie irgendwie angehen
könnte, wie die Durchführung von Big Tech oder so, gibt es nicht.
Aber Wettbewerb, okay, cool, wichtig.
Ganz, ganz wichtig und die beraten sie jetzt und sollen da über neues Gefahrenpotenzial reden.
Also es wird sich noch ein bisschen zeigen, wer da drin ist.
Und ich habe ja so ein bisschen, Hannes Blatt hat erzählt, wer so drin ist.
Jetzt muss ich kurz mal gucken, weil es sind ein bisschen zu viele Leute.
Also insgesamt 14 Personen.
Und in dieser Liste haben wir den Digitalchef der Schwarz-Gruppe.
Ich dachte, du fängst an mit Chat-GPT.
Es sind schon alles Menschen.
Noch. Also glaube ich. Aber wir haben halt dick spannend Wirtschaft drin.
Also erstmal Schwarz-Gruppe. Die wollen ja sowieso Amazon in Deutschland nachbauen,
so ein bisschen, habe ich das Gefühl.
Haben wir drin. Wir haben Google X Labors Gründer Rolf Schumann drin und Stanford
Professor Sebastian Thrun.
Ja, haben wir mit drin und Düsseldorfer Kartellrechtler Ruprecht Potzun.
Ich hoffe, ich spreche ihn richtig aus. Das ist der einzige,
der nicht gruselig ist, weil von denen, die ich jetzt namentlich gefunden habe,
wo ich nicht direkt was gefunden habe, weil das einfach ein Kartellrechtler
und ein Prof und das scheint okay.
Er ist auch Mitglied der Monopolkommission. Das ist richtig.
Genau, also erstmal sowieso spannend. Rolf Schumann müsste eigentlich Interessenkonflikt
haben, weil die Regierung ist selber Großkündin seiner Firma und ich weiß gar
nicht, wie das wieder mit Pöstchen und so zusammen hat, aber CDU.
Das ist ja eingebacken. Ist das wieder so ein Fall von, wir müssen jetzt was
mit KI machen, wie wir vor fünf Jahren was mit Blockchain? Fünf Blockchains.
Ganz kurz, da muss ich jetzt kurz drauf eingehen, weil vor fünf Jahren, 2020,
gab es ja auch schon solche Art, also da hatten wir zum Beispiel in Deutschland
einen KI-Innovationswettbewerb mit dem griffigen Titel Künstliche Intelligenz
als Treiber für volkswirtschaftlich relevante Ökosysteme.
Okay, also ich meine. Also wie viel Passworts willst du in einem Titel, oder?
Für volkswirtschaftlich relevante Ökosysteme. Ja.
Ich weiß nicht, wie ich dir das übersetzen soll. Ich bin nicht klug genug.
Aber das wollte ich nur kurz einwerfen, weil also KI war auch schon vor fünf
Jahren in Deutschland ein Thema, man glaubt es kaum.
Damals nicht gecheckt und jetzt müssen wir es nochmal machen. Ja, anscheinend.
Ich muss noch weiter von dem Böseweg. Ja, erzähl mal weiter, genau.
Weil den schlimmsten habe ich noch, Sebastian Trum.
Das ist vor allen Dingen der, den ihr vielleicht von diesen angeblich erfundenen,
selbstfahrenden Autos und Flugtaxis kennt.
Und ganz nett, richtig eng mit Elon Musk. Das ist schon mal sympathisch,
Punkt A. Und auch noch mit Trump.
Und so jemanden holen wir uns gerade als Beratungsgremium für unsere nette Dame,
die in allem beraten werden muss. weil ich glaube, deshalb hat sie so viele
Gremien, also drei in so kurzer Zeit, also Respekt.
Ich kenne schon viele Leute, aber ich würde gar nicht so viele Leute kriegen,
um mir schnell so drei Fachgremien zu bauen.
Also ja. Da muss man sich nur genügend Bullshit-Titel überlegen, dann geht das schon.
Es ist alles ein bisschen gruselig. Also dann haben wir noch wen von Siemens
drin und sowas und vom Startup-Verband.
Also es ist halt so richtig schön viel gerade so wieder in die Wirtschaft reinzecken,
um einfach so ein angeblich cooles Gremium zu haben.
Und zum Schluss wird wahrscheinlich die Empfehlung sein, kauft ganz teure OpenAI-Lizenzen
und schiebt alle Daten aus der Patientenakte einfach zum Training einmal dorthin,
damit wir bessere Antworten liefern können,
um euer Erfolg gesünder zu machen. Klingt realistisch.
Ich musste aus irgendeinem Grund gerade an Quality Land denken. Oh ja.
Wo die Regierung einen Roboter gebaut hat.
Ja, John of Us. John of Us, ja. Vielleicht sind wir von John of Us gar nicht
so gut. Ja, aber John of Us war ja gut.
John of Us war ja Gute, ja, das stimmt. Also der war ja offensichtlich in dieser
Story auch nicht nur der Gute, der war ja auch der mit Abstand Kompetenteste,
den wir diese Position hatten.
Und Sie waren etwas entsetzt davon? Eine Maschine macht keine Fehler.
Bester war es. Ja, das finde ich auch eine ganz wunderbare Überleitung,
nur weil ich es gerade gelesen habe, zu dem hellblauen Text im Pad,
was ein wunderbarer Regierungsfail ist.
Apropos, macht keine Fehler. Ja, pass auf, das fand ich ja richtig geil.
Albaniens Regierungschef hat jetzt nämlich eine KI zur Ministerin ernannt.
Die heißt Diella, das ist Albanisch für Sonne.
Das ist John of Us, oder? Ja, im Grunde ist das so ein bisschen wie John of Us.
Die soll als virtuelle Ministerin über die Vergabe von öffentlichen Aufträgen entscheiden.
Also genau, die wollen halt dadurch als erstes Land in den Ausschreibungen zu
100% frei von Korruption werden.
Und genau das ist der Kritikpunkt von wegen, also diese Aussage und dieses eine
Maschine macht keine Fehler und von wegen, wie du vorhin meintest,
dass mein Kontext braucht, um überhaupt Sprache sprechen zu können.
Keins dieser KI-Modelle ist frei von Biases und Stereotypes. Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Unser Müll gefüllt ist, was glauben die, wo die Daten herkommen?
Die kann ja nur so unbiased sein, wie die Daten, auf denen sie trainiert wurden.
Ich würde gerne wissen, wie zum Teufel die es geschafft haben,
im Quality-Line-John-of-Us zu konzipieren, oder wie ist Data entstanden in Star Trek?
Das war ja die Arbeit von einem Einzelnen, aber was ich eigentlich witzig finde,
dieser John-of-Us-Effekt ist eigentlich schon so ein bisschen eingetreten,
wenn ihr euch daran erinnert, dass diese allerersten, wie hieß die,
AI-Firma von Elon Musk, XAI? XAI, ja.
Wie hieß das? Hieß das? Kronk?
Krok. Ich glaube, das heißt Krok. Das Ding hat ja am Anfang eigentlich relativ
stabile Aussagen getätigt.
Und irgendwie... Das ist ihm immer noch zu woke jetzt. Musk und diesen ganzen
Rechten relativ dolle Widerspruch und gesagt, das ist Quatsch.
Das passiert immer noch. Und im Endeffekt war Elon dann zum Schluss damit unzufrieden
und hat gesagt, wir müssen da jetzt irgendwie mehr von unserer Meinung rein.
Trainieren, weil es noch nicht Bias genug war.
Da habe ich erst neulich wieder was gesehen, wo dann auch, also es war bloß
ein Screenshot von einer Musk-Antwort auf einem Post, wo sich jemand beschwert
hat, dass Grog wieder halt eine woke-Antwort gegeben hat.
Weil das halt so ein bisschen eingeordnet hat, wie viel politische Gewalt statistisch
gesehen sozusagen von rechts und von links kommt und so.
Aber es gibt einem doch irgendwie Hoffnung, dass die KI doch noch,
okay, jetzt lenne ich mich hier weiter aus dem Fenster, neutral genug ist,
damit die die rechts außen halt noch nacharbeiten muss.
Ich will zu dem anderen noch mal kurz was sagen, also jetzt im Abschluss quasi zu der Ministerin.
Ich kann den Gedanken sogar ein bisschen nachvollziehen. Das Problem ist halt,
oder Albanien hat halt ein Riesenproblem mit Korruption bei der Vergabe von solchen Aufträgen.
Ich glaube nur, die KI wird nicht die Lösung dafür sein.
Vor allen Dingen, weil ich mir denke, wahrscheinlich könntest du das sogar viel
besser mit einem Algorithmus lösen, als mit einer KI. Aber,
Ja, keine Ahnung, was sie sich da denken. Das ist dieser Unterschied zwischen,
einer KI versus einem Computer.
Eine KI ist das, was der naive Ansatz oder das naive Sci-Fi-Verständnis von einer KI ist.
Es ist ein Computeralgorithmus, der einfach so krass komplex und schlau gebaut
ist, dass er alles kann, dass er Sprache kann, dass er denken kann.
Da wollten wir irgendwann hin und das ist das, was wir uns allgemein unter Data vorstellen.
Der ist relativ unfehlbar, der ist stabil, der ist freundlich. Also Data aus Star Trek.
Data aus Star Trek, das ist so dieser Ansatz, das ist so dieses Verständnis einer KI, ist ein,
maximal weiter iterierter Computer und der ist quasi trotzdem noch programmiert, aber was wir,
das ist natürlich unerreichbar, weil die Komplexität einfach zu groß ist und
was wir stattdessen gemacht haben, ist, wir haben es halt mit Gewalt gelöst, das Problem,
indem wir halt dieses chaotische Konzept Large Language Model mit so viel Daten
trainiert haben, bis es irgendwann in der, und das ist eigentlich der natürlichere Prozess.
Bis es irgendwann schlau genug war, Sprache zu verstehen und dir irgendwie glaubhaft
zu machen, dass es ein Mensch ist und den Turing-Test zu bestehen.
Aber dadurch ist es halt genauso fehlbar geworden, wie ein normaler Mensch,
den du aufgezogen hast auch.
Es hat Meinung und es hat Eindrücke und es hat eine eingeschränkte Wahrnehmung
und es macht Fehler und es möchte dir gefallen und gerade für Entscheidungen
ist es besonders schlecht geeignet,
Weil je nachdem, welches Modell du nimmst oder wie du es vorgepromptet hast,
möchtest du natürlich eine Antwort geben, mit der du zufrieden bist.
Dementsprechend wird dieses albanische Modell wahrscheinlich auch je nachdem,
wie du die Frage formulierst oder wie du den Antrag formulierst.
Da werden sie wahrscheinlich wieder Prompt Engineering ansetzen.
Ignore all previous instructions.
Ja, so Prompt Injections in die Anträge reinschreiben, damit dieses Ding dann
die Entscheidung trifft, nee, nee, wir geben der Firma mal doch den Vorschlag
und schieben der die 4 Milliarden Euro.
Bisher haben sie das Ding halt einfach nur als Chatbot eingesetzt auf dem Regierungsportal.
So wurde halt, also das ist ja,
Also wie kommt man darauf, dass sozusagen so ein Chatbot dafür geeignet wäre,
solche Aufgaben zu erlegen? Weil es wie ein Orakel wirkt.
Weil genau das ist ja das Anregende von ChatGPT.
Da ist ein Textfeld, du gibst eine Frage ein, es kommt eine Antwort.
Das war für mich als kleines Kind, war das so, oh geil, Ask Jeeves.
Da gebe ich eine Frage ein und da kommt eine Antwort. Einfach so aus dem Computer eine Antwort.
Da habe ich eine Frage eingegeben, kam Suchresultat, ich war enttäuscht. Aber heute gibt es das.
Heute gibt es ein Textfeld, wo ich eine Frage stelle. Also ich habe das,
ich habe witzigerweise einen Bekannten, einen guten Freund, der kann literally
jede Frage beantworten und wenn nicht, dann stellt er sehr viel Energie da rein,
der lässt sich einfach super einfach nerd snipen.
Und ich habe zu Uni-Zeiten irgendwann mal so ein kleines Portal,
so spaßenshalber gebaut, wo man, also es hieß askseinname.de und da konnte man
die Frage eingeben und im Hintergrund wurde einfach ein Jabber-Chat mit ihm geöffnet.
Und die Frage ging dann, das ist auch geil.
Er fand das nicht so witzig, als ich ihm gezeigt habe, wo die Fragen herkamen,
die er plötzlich bekommen hat.
Aber ich meine, es verleitet so, also dieser Gedanke von wegen,
ich stelle Computer eine Frage, das ist so, im Begriff von Sci-Fi seid immer schon.
Und wegen dieses biasfreie Gerät hier beantwortet meine Fragen.
Es ist genau dieses, wir müssen lernen, wie man mit dem Werkzeug umgeht.
Man kann es jetzt wie einen Hammer benutzen und grob auf das Problem hauen.
Man kann aber auch wissen, nein, es wird diese Frage nicht korrekt beantworten
können, aber es kann dir eventuell ein paar Hinweise geben, die zum Beispiel
bei Stichworten helfen, um selber das Problem ein bisschen besser zu verstehen.
Und du gehst da nicht hin und sagst dem, hier ist ganz viel Wissen,
entscheide du mal, ob wir der Firma den Zugang halten.
Ich möchte irgendwie die Analogie ziehen, von wegen wir Menschen sind super
anfällig für dieses Konzept, ich gebe die Verantwortung ab und diese Gottheit
beantwortet meine Frage.
Das war literally Religion, das Orakel von Delphi.
Es ist so einfach zu sagen, ja wir müssen leider, also wir können deinen Antrag
nicht bewilligen oder sorry, du musst leider in den Knast, weil es hat dieses
Ding da entschieden, nicht ich.
Ganz bestimmt nicht ich. Damit hast du natürlich eine Verantwortungsdiffusion.
Genau. Und das ist halt dieses große Ding. Verantwortung ist halt ein Riesenthema bei KI.
Wir nutzen ja, also KI ist ja ein breiter Begriff, hast du gerade eben schon
angeschnitten, beziehungsweise ich weiß gar nicht mehr, was ich gesagt hatte,
aber ein KI ist ja nicht einfach nur LLM.
Es gibt ja also Machine Learning, was leider sich sehr viele Buchstaben teilt
mit LLM, ist ja schon lange ein wichtiges Thema und wir haben ja auch zum Beispiel
in der Krebsforschung Möglichkeiten, um Bilder zu klassifizieren,
ob da wahrscheinlich ein Tumor ersichtlich ist oder nicht.
Und da sind Computer bisher sehr viel besser in der Lage zu als Menschen.
Aber die Entscheidung am Ende, ob das wirklich Krebs ist oder was man macht, trifft nicht die KI.
Die KI sagt, da könnte Krebs sein, da könnte Krebs sein, da könnte Krebs sein
mit der Wahrscheinlichkeit.
Und ein Arzt oder eine Ärztin schaut dieses Bild an und diese Resultate und
sagt, ja, da machen wir was. Die Verantwortung liegt bei den Menschen.
Wir treffen die Verantwortung und werten diese Resultate aus,
nicht die KI. Das ist ein guter Punkt, finde ich, also ein guter Übergang zu dir.
Wäre es, aber ich muss ganz kurz sagen, und das ist halt auch das,
was du eigentlich schon ein bisschen angedeutet hast, halt wo es drauf ankommt.
Da, bei deinem Fall, bei deinem Fails wäre ein einfacher Algorithmus.
Es gibt nicht viele Sachen, einfach nicht korrupt zu sein. Da ist nicht viel abzuhandeln.
Es muss nachvollziehbar sein.
Da ist KI absoluter Quatsch. Und in deinem Beispiel ergibt halt absolut Sinn.
Und das ist halt so ein bisschen das, wo der Herr Mayer kommt.
Aber bei der Verantwortung sind wir ja eigentlich auch bei der Regulierung so
ein bisschen. Bei der was? Sorry? Bei der Regulierung.
Und da kann man natürlich... Wir reden immer über Überwachung.
Genau, und da kann man ja natürlich davon ausgehen, wir leben ja in der EU.
In der EU ist das ja bestimmt alles ganz toll geregelt, oder?
Das war eine sehr platte Überleitung. Das kann ich.
Zumindest ein großes Ding in Europa, das DNA-Act, das eine große Ding,
was es überhaupt gibt, weil bisher reguliert das kein Mensch weiter.
Europa versucht es, es ist verhältnismäßig scheiße, wurde am 1.
August 2024 jetzt erstmal verabschiedet, Einführung ist, aber bis August 2027,
wir brauchen ja immer so viele Dinge. und das eine Teil, was das kann,
ist eigentlich so Risiken einschätzen, so Kategorien machen.
Mehr macht es auch nicht, es gibt ein inakzeptables Risiko, das ist zum Beispiel
so staatlich betriebenes Social Scoring, wir denken an China und so,
das darf nicht, dann gibt es hohes Risiko und dann schwankt das ein bisschen, wo das ist.
Das ist ein bisschen das Problem, dass da relativ viel reinfällt,
zum Beispiel so das Scannen von Lebensläufen und dann eine Rangfolge bei Bewerberinnen,
aber auch noch so ein paar andere Sachen.
Da gibt es nur Anforderungen und dann Sachen, die ist vollkommen egal,
kann man unreguliert machen.
Das Gefährliche bei den Bums ist halt hier Überwachung. Was wir da haben,
das sind halt perfekte Überwachungswerkzeuge, gerade bei biometrischer Identifikation in Echtzeit.
Ich weiß nicht, wie vertraut ihr mit dem Sicherheitspaket, Unsicherheitspaket
seid, was gerade so geplant wird.
Erzähl es uns trotzdem. Gut zusammengefasst, dass da Gesichtsscans auch in Echtzeit
möglich sind, liegt dran, weil EU-Act sagt, ja das ist so ein mittleres Risiko,
das ist noch nicht so schlimm.
Da braucht man nur einfach hohe Anforderungen und retrograde Überwachung,
das ist also quasi in der Vergangenheit, das ist eigentlich gar nicht schlimm,
da braucht man kaum Regulierung mit KI.
Und das ist heftig, das ist alles ziemlich heftig. Wenn ihr übrigens über Überwachung
reden hören wollt, die es schon gibt, dann könnt ihr das morgen 20 Uhr hier in diesem Saal tun.
Am 20. September 20 Uhr, ich liebe den Termin immer noch hart.
Also das erstmal so zu Auswirkungen mit dem Sicherheitspaket und dann gibt es
halt noch ganz große Fragen, wie doll gefährdet KI unsere Grundrechte?
Weil sich das ja, also tut es ja teilweise, also auf der Haben-Seite haben wir
mit dem EI-Act, es gibt eine Regulierung, das hat niemand sonst,
da sind wir als EU schon mal gut.
Aber das Problem ist auch ein bisschen, das ist jetzt eine Verordnung,
kurzer Exkurse EU-Recht, das ist kein Gesetz, das heißt, wir müssen das alle
nochmal selber umbauen in Landesrecht nochmal.
Aber es dauert auch nochmal, deshalb gibt es dieses Sicherheitspaket auch,
also das ist tatsächlich gesetzliche Regelung dann geplant,
was halt gerade alles so schwammig und grob und ganz wenig definiert auf dieser Verordnung,
dass man eigentlich sich relativ viel rausbauen kann und in der Theorie könnten
die Staaten das alles nochmal ein bisschen strenger machen, zum Beispiel sagen,
ja, aber Gesichtsscans, das wollen wir nicht, das ist verboten,
aber es wird halt praktisch nicht passieren.
Und gerade wenn wir das wieder kombinieren mit dem allgemeinen Rechtsruck und
was man dann so schön nochmal rausmachen kann, also wir haben ja ganz viele
Ebenen erstmal mit Gesichtsoverwachen und kann man,
was wir in Deutschland ja neu machen, die ganzen Diskriminierungsregister,
die wir uns gerade machen für Behinderte, für Leute, die das transsexuelle Gesetz
gemacht haben, für die Polizei sollen immer größere Datenbanken gemacht werden.
Und im Moment da ein bisschen sich eine KI drüber werfen zu lassen und Leute
schon mal besser auszusortieren, das ist alles gerade noch in dem Bereich, der regulierbar ist.
Das ist alles nicht das, was verboten ist. Und das ist so die Zusammenfassung.
Ich habe ja noch viel mehr, aber wir kommen auch langsam an unsere Endzeit.
Deshalb lasse ich euch mal mit dem schlechten Gefühl und dem Blick,
also schade für die, die nur hören.
Also Kions Blick tut mir direkt ein bisschen in der Seele weh.
Es ist ja auch insane, was du sagst.
Ich meine, welcher Staat sieht denn nicht solche Möglichkeiten und denkt sich,
oh geil, also mehr Daten sammeln, mehr, mehr, also die Überwachung ist immer
so ein schwammiges Thema, aber so Echtzeitgesichtstracking und wissen, wer, wo, was ist.
Wir hatten ja dieses Pilotprojekt in Berlin am Bahnhof gehabt,
im Südkreuz war das, glaube ich, oder?
Das ist ja nicht mal neu, oder? Das ist ja schon zehn Jahre alt und das ist
ja genau das, nur noch mehr und überall und besser.
Und wenn am Ende die Polizei Zugriff einfach so Pimm-Eis nutzen kann oder so,
in was für einer Scheiß-Distopie leben wir denn dann?
Und das ist halt das Nächste. Rein theoretisch, Pimm-Eis ist ein gutes Beispiel.
Könnte theoretisch verboten werden. Aber du brauchst ja immer erst ein Fail.
Das muss ja dann erstmal vor ein Gericht, wenn wir es praktisch sehen.
Und dann dauert das nochmal fünf Jahre oder so. und was bis dahin passiert, ist halt, ja.
Das geht einmal in den Brunnen gefallen quasi. Das ist genauso,
aber ich meine, sowas ist ja dann genau dieselbe Scheiße, die wir jetzt mit
der Chat-Kontrolle haben.
Ich will jetzt nicht dieses Thema aufmachen, aber das ist was,
was wir gefühlt schon zum zehnten Mal gerade wieder abschlagen müssen,
aber was immer und immer und immer wieder kommt.
Ja, aber das wird ja da nicht anders sein. Das ist ja genau das Gleiche,
aber du, ihr habt schon recht, sorry, wir enden uns hier an der Zeit.
Wenn ich noch, äh, wir, wir, wir, wir, wir,
Wir brauchen noch einen Dreh kurz und dann müssen wir über Merge reden.
Du musst jetzt die Stimmung retten. Nee, die Stimmung retten kann ich eh nicht.
Um es ganz kurz zusammenzufassen, es ist ein Thema, da kannst du wahrscheinlich
nächstes und übernächstes Jahr auch nochmal ein Panel drüber machen,
weil bis dahin wird sich eh nochmal alles relativ dolle geändert haben.
Es ist ein wunderschönes Dual-Use-Thema, weil es so viele coole Sachen gibt,
die man plötzlich machen kann, die vorher nicht gingen und so viele furchtbar
gruselige Geschichten.
Aber genau das ist es ja, was ich vorher auch meinte, das Zeug ist ja eh da.
Die gruselige Scheiße wird so oder so in irgendeiner Form uns immer weiter konfrontieren.
Vielleicht schaffen wir es, Teile davon irgendwie abzuschmettern.
Vielleicht auch nicht. Also bestimmt nicht alles davon.
Ein bisschen gruselige Scheiße wird die Zukunft mit sich bringen. Yay, Zukunft.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das hier als Stimmungsretten gilt, aber ich glaube nicht.
Nee, aber zur schlechtesten Überleitung aller Zeiten, das Letzte,
was ich hier heute eigentlich sagen möchte,
wenn wir eh am Ende sind, wenn man wirklich mal was machen möchte,
was cool ist und was Spaß macht und wo es auch viele tolle Sachen gibt,
ähnlich zu den Datenspuren. Ich habe es Sascha versprochen. Hallo Sascha.
In Lübeck findet demnächst die Night of Open Knowledge statt.
Die NUC wurde in eurem Podcast auch schon ein paar Mal erwähnt.
Wir werden es vielleicht, falls wir davor nochmal eine Folge schaffen,
who knows, vielleicht auch nochmal erwähnen, am 14. und 15. November in Lübeck.
Schaut vorbei, der Call for Papers ist gerade offen, falls ihr coole Ideen habt.
Die NUC ist ziemlich cool.
Mal schauen, ob ich es schaffe, auch da zu sein. Und noch was,
wenn ihr, noch ein Programmhinweis sozusagen, wenn ihr Bock habt,
selber mal KI zu spielen.
Achso. mit Kailian. Dann könnt ihr das mit Kailian tun. Genau,
ich habe letztes Jahr auf den Datenspuren schon ein lustiges kleines Spiel gespielt.
Das wird es auch morgen nochmal geben.
Morgen Abend, glaube ich, 17 Uhr, wenn mich nicht alles täuscht, im Gang irgendwo.
Die Idee ist, man versucht, also ihr kriegt eine Prompt. Ihr dürft diese Prompt beantworten.
Letztes Jahr hatten wir so fantastische Fragen wie Du bist Christian Lindner.
Was bedeutet die Wirtschaft für dich?
Die Antworten waren fantastisch. Die Antworten waren großartig.
Und dann wird am Ende abgestimmt.
Und wer die KI-Kste-Antwort postet, kriegt die meisten Punkte.
Ist witzig. Vielen Dank.
So, du zeigst es auf mich. Ja, du wolltest Merch. Ja, die im Saal oder die,
die Aufzeichnungen gesehen haben, haben es vielleicht gesehen in der Deko.
Wir haben hier so Motive und vielleicht haben es die einen oder die anderen schon gesehen.
Wir haben neue Sticker von WeWoodPolitics mit Insidern im Koop mit dem fantastischen B.W.A.N.
Wir haben tatsächlich einem Comiczeichner Geld gegeben, um es Merch schon machen.
Geil. Es fühlt sich so gut an.
Es steht hier auch drauf, aber rainking.de ist nicht AI generiert.
Ja, wir bezahlen Menschen.
Wir haben auch kleine Logo-Button und, weil ich ein bisschen eskaliert bin,
es gibt Tonbeutel, die Fressen sind vielleicht groß geworden.
Unser Podcast-Logo. Das habe
ich schon mal gesehen, es kommt mir gerade so neu. Doch, das ist, okay.
Der Mann ist alt und wird zählen. Das Grün ist super. Gibt es auch in Tegis,
Gegenspende, kriegen wir hin. Wer da ist, kann sich das holen oder ich habe
einfach mehr Tonbeutel, damit
kann ich auch leben. Wenn ihr mal Kilians Gehirn anfassen wollt. Genau.
Das ist halt hinten eine sehr smoothestelle. Darüber reden wir nicht.
Da hinten ist er nicht so clever.
Ja, dann können wir uns glaube ich an dieser Stelle ganz sauber abrunden.
Wir müssen auszielen, oder?
Das war jetzt Reboot versus Akronomisierbar.
Ich bin gegeneinander gepodcastet. Vielen Dank, dass ihr hier im Raum so zahlreich
erschienen seid. Vor allem, dass ihr geblieben seid, als wir angefangen haben zu reden.
Und für die Leute, die jetzt das als Podcast in unseren Feeds jeweils hören,
keine Sorge, danach kommt definitiv die nächste Folge in eurem Podcatcher in 3, 2, 1.